so one of the things we teach you is in
the house of the wise proverb says our
stores of choice food and oil wise
people save money and a foolish man
devours all he has if you spend
everything you make God says you're a
fool I didn't say it don't give him
ahead of me it's in the Bible a foolish
man devours only has at times in my life
I've been a foolish man on a lot of
different ways but spending was one of
them for sure I can spend some money
that's why God makes me teach this
everyday and this is the week where
America celebrates our ability to spend
I mean it's Black Friday followed by
Cyber Monday followed by green Tuesday
followed by I'm in the red Thursday I
don't know I mean there's something go
there's a lot of colors going on right
there's a problem here now I don't want
you to not enjoy Christmas and I don't
want you to never buy I don't want to do
Dave Ramsey he mean once you live in a
cave and collect lint and only come out
on a triple coupon Thursday I'll shut up
whiner that is not what I said I've
never said that one time I don't say
that at all I want you to live your life
I just don't want your life to eat you
alive because you don't have any off
button you can't stop I had a pug for
awhile as a great dog the dog could not
stop eating it would eat everything you
put in front of it and it would it
almost turned into an English bulldog he
got so fat I mean it got so fat and
because my wife is like look it's hungry
it is not hungry
there's nothing hungry about this dog it
did not have an off button for food and
so we had to simply just not put out so
much food is that that's the deal and if
you don't have an off button for
spending you've got a problem this week
because you're gonna justify rationalize
and generally BS yourself into
bankruptcy court on
like Friday now I want you to go get you
some stuff I'm not mad about stuff I
don't think you ought to not have stuff
I just don't want your stuff to have you
and I don't want you to spend money that
you don't have trying to find happiness
stuff never equals happiness stuff is
fun I've got some nice stuff and some of
that stuff is fun I got a really nice
ski boat it is really fun but it doesn't
make you happy and if you get
philosophically spiritually confused
about fun and happiness you can spend
yourself searching for happiness and
really all you can ever buy with money
is fun you can't buy happiness godliness
with contentment is great gain so don't
be a foolish man the devours all he has
be wise be a grown-up go into Black
Friday with an actual plan purchase some
stuff for your family but don't do it in
the name of it's gonna make a
relationship okay if I don't get daddy a
gift daddy will be mad but we have other
issues because if you have to buy
someone's relationship that's called
prostitution and so if you're if you're
trying to make broken relationships
right with a purchase you're gonna
struggle your whole life with money and
you're living an illusion and so don't
buy stuff for someone to make them feel
better about you that won't work it
won't work and don't buy stuff to make
you feel better about you that won't
work
get you some stuff just to enjoy having
a nice car to enjoy having a nice
experience to enjoy you know the way it
feels to wear a really nice suit that's
fine I've got no issue with that at all
but don't do this out of a wrong
motivation where you're trying to make
yourself happy with stuff or other
people happy with stuff or
you're gonna heal broken relationships
with purchases this is very childish and
this is a very bad plan the number of
people that spend money just to keep
family happy during Christmas that cause
families dysfunctional is unbelievable
the pressure you feel if I don't do it
if I don't do it gift at this level my
sister Ruby mid see this is just this is
just four year old stuff not 34 year old
stuff and that is not the you know what
you need to do is have a different
discussion and it's the discussion has
nothing to do with the size of the gift
the discussion has to do with the
quality of the relationship between the
giver and the receiver and that changes
everything in other words the gifts
really should not matter in the
relationships at all and the gift should
not matter in your search for happiness
then it's just stuff you ever meet
somebody that completely freaks out and
melts down because an item got destroyed
or messed up like a car got bumped into
or someone spilled something on their
nice purse or someone spilled something
on grandmother's couch and grandmother
has to go into the padded cell for three
days and get medication because their
couch got something spilled on it see
this is someone who's worshiping a couch
they're trying to get something from a
couch that a couch cannot give it cannot
give you a sense of satisfaction it
cannot give you happiness it cannot give
you contentment it doesn't have the
capacity to a purse can't do that as
soon as clothes can't do that a car
can't do that a trip can't do that it's
okay to get you a nice couch you know
when I was a kid most of my early
childhood we have this big wonderful
room in the front of our house that we
kids all played in it was called the
living room had no furniture in it at
all
I was like 13 years old and I came home
and my dad had made a commission check
and they furnished the living room with
new furniture and we were kind of bummed
out we liked having this gymnasium in
the front of our house
don't try to get stuff to do stuff if
something you do it won't do it it's
okay to get you some stuff enjoy Black
Friday but don't go to Walmart stand in
line get in a fight over who gets a TV
that makes you look stupid and it makes
the rest of us in America look stupid
that's ridiculous